[Music]
so I think we should understand that a
system of free trade is clearly the best
system for the global economy there is
nothing else that will work as well it
drives more growth
it makes your products cheaper it is
vastly more efficient than anything else
we've ever found so if we move away from
free trade the American economy will
grow less the global economy will grow
less I support free trade but I fully
understand that there are very
legitimate reasons why lots of Americans
do not because despite all the growth of
the US and global economy and despite
the share prices of corporations being
through the roof many at record levels
they the average Americans have not
benefited from free trade in the way
that they said that the leaders have
said they were going to yes you know
prices of goods have gone down but if
you lose your job because it went to
another country and if no one's
investing in your kids school system or
in your health system or in your
infrastructure locally if you're in a
rural area or a blighted second or
third-tier urban area there's no reason
for you to say oh I'll continue to
support free trade agreements because
you've been lied to from presidents and
CEOs and the mainstream media and
political leaders from both parties for
decades now they haven't cared about you
so when Trump comes along and says the
system is rigged even if he's not the
answer even if he's not gonna make it
better for you you kind of feel like
yeah the system is rigged against me all
these people have lied and and I'll tell
you you know my brother voted for Trump
if my mother were alive she would have
voted for Trump she read the National
Inquirer every week and it felt more
real to her then the Boston Globe did or
even the Boston Herald because the
National Enquirer was all about telling
people that the system is rigged against
them and so I think this has been coming
for a long time I think that one of the
reasons why Trump
has maintained the very consistent and
strong support from his Republican base
that he has is because he has been quite
consistent in trying to implement many
if not almost all of his campaign
promises no matter how well or badly
that would work out for him so for
example he wants to build a wall I think
most people that understand policy
understand that's a waste of money it
would be a stupid idea and it's only
gonna symbolically serve to get people
to not want to come to the US that we
might want to attract the people that
really have choices but he promised the
wall he is actually trying really hard
to build a wall he said the Chinese are
taking us to the cleaners they're
ripping us off that the Europeans are
ripping us off his push back against the
Europeans the Chinese and others both in
terms of trade directly and with our
allies in terms of you better spend more
money on defense or else has been much
harder than we've seen from previous
presidents so I'm not suggesting that
these policies are actually going to
work so far I would say the jury is very
much out and initial results are
extremely mixed but I do believe that if
you're thinking about voting for someone
because they are a different style of
politician that everyone lies to you and
we know that Trump is a very damaged
individual you don't want your kids to
grow up to be like Trump he doesn't lead
by example but you wanted someone who
would at least shake things up and maybe
break things it wasn't like every other
politician
well Trump's promise of shaking things
up and breaking things back when he was
running for president he does appear to
actually be authentic in that desire
[Music]